are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset they're saying we believe
that's it
i thought uh
we're live
okay are we live or no we're official
africa we're live folks i literally just
put the heads up thank you for that
the headphones you want
to join this is episode number 157 today
we have with us mark moreno which uh if
you don't know who he is
uh he is uh one of five uh criminals
against humanity against planet earth
itself
uh in 2009 the eco magazine grist said
he was one of the five the other four
were bjorn lumberg
uh richard lindsen senator james inhofe
and president george w bush he was rush
limbaugh's man in washington
former republican political aide who uh
founded and runs climate depot and
probably world's number one climate
contrarian with that being said mark
thank you so much for being a guest
thank you pat i'm happy to be here yes
it's good to have you on i was watching
a lot of your content and i've i've seen
you with you and bill nye and and you
know what i did when you were speaking
all i did is focus on bill nye i'm like
when he gets upset his facial
expressions i don't know if you did you
see that or no have you seen it the way
he was getting agitated by it was just
entertaining to me
to see and then you know i you know i've
been following this uh topic of climate
change i think it's actually the next
thing that's gonna
uh be used by the media a lot i think
for some people that are creating
content i have a feeling they may if
there was covid that were videos that
were
being taken down i think climate change
maybe some of the next videos that may
be taken down in censor but at the same
time
what i want to get with you today
is
there are a lot of people that are very
smart
who
fully believe
this is taking place it's coming and i'm
not talking about greta thonberg i'm not
talking about aoc
i'm not even putting al gore in that mix
these are politicians uh i'm not talking
president obama who said this is the
this is the biggest crisis that we
should pay attention to i'm not talking
about bernie sanders bette midler um not
john kerry not jane fonda not leonardo
dicaprio but i'm talking about
an elon musk the way he explained it you
know the i don't know if you've seen the
12-minute speech he gives when he breaks
down what's going on with the
temperature we're two degrees to some of
us may not be a big deal
and then he says you know five degrees
uh of new york city five degrees has he
explained it new york city would be
under ice uh minus five degrees and new
york city would be underwater plus five
degrees and that's not just a regular
guy who says that he's a guy that'll
call out [ __ ] so when he says that
he makes me think but prior to us
getting into the questions that we have
here if you don't mind the audience who
maybe doesn't know your story give us a
little bit about your background and how
you came to the conclusion of
this may just be a hoax and maybe
they're selling it from the other side
as the next massive crisis i will i
actually just want to say one thing
about uh
about musk
fascinating figure i i don't know what
year that speech you're referring to do
you remember when it was done that oh i
can pull it up i can see what euro was
i'll get it right now what his views are
now on climate post covid but elon musk
is was in a position for years he wasn't
five years ago that was five years ago
but he wasn't always the rebel
especially the free speech rebel you see
today because maybe he wasn't needed to
be but essentially he was relying on a
lot of government contracts a lot of the
of support that he sort of played along
he was a big promoter of climate change
fears um and it'd be interesting to see
now what he's doing there the two
degrees and we can talk about it later
he's just using with the un when that
number the two degrees celsius
temperature was literally pulled out of
thin air
just to give the public something to
latch on to this was admitted by top u.n
scientists in the climate gate emails so
all the unm musk what you're referring
to is saying oh two degrees is what the
u.n says and here's what could might may
happen if that scenario it's kind of
like saying we're going to go on a
family vacation but if the car hits a
tractor-trailer here's what could happen
and they're going to show dead bodies in
the highway i mean that's that's
basically that's easy it's simple it's
cheap politics and i and i like elon
musk now same by the way just to say
elon musk
robert f kennedy jr uh these are people
that are huge climate fear promoters in
my new book i publicly essentially
forgive them especially robert f kennedy
jr one of the jail climate skeptics in
an interview i did with him he said we
belong at the hague with three square
three squares and a cot with all the
other war criminals and i forgive him
because the way he came around on on uh
covet and was just one of the most
incredible anti-tyrannical anti-tyranny
speakers oh he got censored by instagram
by everybody i mean we've had him on
multiple times and every time videos
would get flagged on what he had to say
this is the number one environmental
attorney in america apparently based on
what a lot of people would say but
please continue okay wait that's all i
want to say there now my background uh
i'm not a scientist i come at this as an
investigative reporter
uh my background actually is a ronald
reagan volunteer for his presidency in
1980.
uh i was going on 12 years old my older
brother worked there so i just went on
saturdays in the fall of 1980 and
actually that piqued my interest in
media and politics because i was giving
audio clips of governor reagan to all
the local things and back then it was
real to real
tape cartridges that got me involved in
politics i always liked the reagan
presidency but i was always considered
myself a
republican except when it came to
environmental issues
and i had taken these tests i always
wanted to be a park ranger i loved
animals i love hunting and uh not
hunting but fishing and hiking
and what happened was
i
during the reagan years just literally
was not happy with his policies but
later on i got caught up in the national
geographic the amazon's going to
disappear the species extinction it
wasn't until the rio earth summit that
uh that that my eyes were essentially
open when i heard claims dixie lee ray
the nuclear physicist was on
is actually on rush limbaugh's radio
show of all things but she was doing
live reports and she was down to doing a
whole bunch of media condemning the un
earth summit that g george w bush george
h.w bush went to in 1992
and that was an eye-opener because she
said the deforestation claims were not
we're all grossly exaggerated it was the
most intact force i remember starting to
investigate that that led to an
environmental awakening which years
later i did an amazon rainforest
documentary and i even got the amazon
scientists in um in brazil to slam down
the travel guide books by saying this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] throwing the
book down because it was all about the
computer models and how many football
fields a minute of the forest were
disappearing turns out amazon most
intact forests on the planet when you
reforest using modern techniques you
can't distinguish between plant and
animal species according to studies and
even the new york times admitted later i
think it was 2006 or seven that for
every acre of rainforest cut 50 are
being regenerated
not to say there aren't challenges but
the biggest thing is people are leaving
the jungle and moving to uh urban areas
and suburban areas so that was the
environmental scare i grew up with so by
the time global warming came along i was
skeptical i worked uh
for a uh like an independent news
magazine show it was called american
investigator and started doing didn't do
climate at the time because that was i
was doing a wetlands endangered species
amazon did a show on organic food and
the impacts it could have on land use
unless they get higher yields
of farming and how they actually had
higher bacterial content
of food production and and that's that
was a fascinating thing because that was
an interesting because that cut across
all ideologies but essentially from
there
investigative reporter then i worked for
the senate environment and public works
committee in the
united states senate and as such i
worked for the ranking member at the
time with senator james inhofe who's
actually retiring this year he's one of
the five yeah one of the five my mom had
a funny comment when that list came out
there's a couple other lists she said
how come i'm the only one on that list
that isn't you know either very powerful
in terms of a position or a lot of money
because it was dealing with all these
you know people she was always
saying that which was silly but my role
at that point was the spokesman
for essentially the senate gop on the
top environmental committee and in that
position did a report of authored a
report of 400 descending scientists
where we got voices from around the
world and then we updated it to i think
it was 600 then 750 then later a
thousand after i left the senate and the
gist of it was we were being told a
fabrication and i became very so my
whole career then became from general
investigative reporter with a focus on
environmental to then focusing almost
exclusively on the environment then i
founded climate depot after i left the
u.s senate
um but essentially
the
one of the biggest things we did was the
dissenting scientists we were told there
was only a dozen scientists the same
amount as the flat earth society who
didn't think that the earth was doomed
by mankind's carbon dioxide
and
that was said by the united nations
climate chief regenda bachari that was
said by al gore that was said by a lot
of the climate activists there's only
two dozen or so this is nonsense there's
the consensus is settled so we came out
with a list we included nobel prize
winners i did sub reports about u.n
scientists who turned against the united
nations talked about it being a
political body masquerading as a science
institution talked about how the
scientific authors would have to bow
their report and summaries to the
politicians and bureaucrats so we
exposed the whole un process for what it
was so anyway that's how i got started
started climate depot and my goal was
to just provide an alternative to most
of journalism out there and you know i
was doing this since 1992 i started with
rush limbaugh's tv show and i was his
man in washington as his dc reporter i
wore a hat and trench coat it was very
much uh
a silly entertainment segment i'd go to
all the capitol hill stuff i got thrown
out of the clinton white house and my
camera confiscated uh and actually helen
thomas the
upi bureau chief marched me into the
white house press office the clinton
office and demanded they return it and
apologized to me
this really offended the media now i
don't know i think most of the media
today would cheer if peter ducey had his
microphone taken away but but i was
essentially uh you know i was a blogger
before they had blogs and i did that
with you know vegeta limbaugh's tv show
so that i got kicked out of democratic
fundraisers i did a lot of coverage of
earth days and all the marches in dc for
rush limbaugh so i've tried to fuse
politics
with entertainment and also science and
one of my goals with climate depot and
with climate science and with the green
new deal and even with covid is to make
everything understandable so that's my
whole
niche if you will i try to make it
entertaining and understandable for the
average person you don't have to be a
scientist don't let them intimidate you
and that's where this 97 and all that
comes from in the climate world they try
to silence you like you don't know more
than same with covid you can't tell me
you don't want to mask your kid anthony
falci is an expert with decades of
experience and degrees you don't know
more than him he knows what's best for
your kids you're nothing but a redneck
in kansas that's the way that's the
mentality of our publishers so so did
you ever see that movie about cigarettes
back in the early 2000s what was it
thank you for smoking thank you thank
you for smoking right so you've seen
taylor yeah yeah what a sick movie right
i mean the sick in a good way like great
action yeah right yes and i watch it i'm
like okay first of all i can't stand
cigarettes i mean i'm i'm somebody that
you know if a salesperson comes to my
house they smoke cigarettes if that if i
shake their hands i'm not buying from
them that's just me i don't like
cigarettes i've never been a fan of
cigarettes to me the smell of cigarettes
is very different than the smell of weed
the smell of cigar there's something
about cigarettes and it's all chemicals
and i mean that's my personal opinion
some people say i can't believe you just
said that i smoke i'm offended
that's my opinion it's how i feel but
when i watched that movie
i sat there and i said
what a freaking great job lobbying
to convince
millions of intelligent people with
common sense
that cigarette doesn't harm you you're
just watching you're like wow what a
great job lobbyists did right
and they and then you know all the
commercials and all this and then
finally people are like listen you're
full of [ __ ] here's a lung smoking
cigarettes yeah here's one not smoking
cigarettes oh that's not the case that's
something else no no this is the reality
with anecdotal well i have an uncle who
lived in 95. yeah so then but what that
took what that took me to was
what other industry or product have we
been convinced
that's good or bad because of brilliant
men like him that are great sales people
great communicators great persuaders who
go around
being witty sharp smart you're like oh
my god this guy knows what he's talking
about he's just kind of back down and
the average person can't you know debate
and have an inner you know interaction
with somebody at that level she's like
you know what i'm not even gonna have
the conversation whatever i'll leave it
alone right right so so for me when i
think about climate change i look at
both sides i try to reason i look at
both sides so on one side they're you
know shoving it down our throat like
neil tyson you know what's his name yeah
he's like well you know at this point of
the game the question isn't whether it's
happening or not there is no such thing
as anti-climate change whatever deniers
it's happening those people don't know
what they're talking about so now that
we know what's happening let's address
it right you can't even have the debate
and then the other side
you know is who wouldn't want that to
happen who who doesn't want the debate
of climate change to happen well
i'm from you know i lived in texas five
years there's a lot of oil guys that
probably don't want this to happen i
would assume that a part of elon musk
selling the fact that we have to be
careful with this is his company is
tesla so the incentive is i sell
insurance i have to sell you right what
the benefit of life insurance he sells
life settlement he's going to sell you
on what life said you have something you
sell you have to sell us on it and we
all have to persuade each other right
but there has to be some somebody that's
right and somebody that's wrong so i had
paul manafort here two weeks ago last
week maybe you know paul manafort is
yeah and he he's a lobbyist you know
he's made millions of dollars just off
lobby and i'm i'm uncomfortable with
lobbyists as well you know if they're
going to use it he's going to use it as
well fine no problem
your argument that you make one may say
mark i mean
you're from rush limbaugh's side i mean
we know where rush stood you know
russia's as right-wing and republican as
he can get he pissed off a lot of people
for 20 years
okay great fine he's a hero to many but
he's hated by many as well i mean the
hero and hate it is in the same category
meaning as far right far left both sides
some may say yeah you know you're
probably just defending your oil guys
and and people who are on your side or
the other your friends you go to parties
with them so you have to say something
like this because if something happens
those guys may use billions of dollars
so you're just helping those guys out
what do you say to people who say that i
get that all the time in fact if you go
to my about page at climate depot
actually someone said and i can't
remember who now but some professor that
i was nick naylor in the flesh embodied
in the flesh on the climate issue
i am not a lobbyist i've never been a
lobbyist i don't lobby i don't go to i
stay as far away from dc as possible
these days but when i worked there i was
a communication director for the senate
environment and public works committee
our my organization i work for a company
called committee for constructive
tomorrow
chiefly and like when i say chiefly 85
80
90 of our money is from direct mail to
the public we are strictly grassroots
the rest of the money might come from
foundations but we do not and you can
look at my about page on wikipedia which
i have no control over they'll say that
the group we had was funded by
exxonmobil well they're very careful in
their wording i've never gotten money
that i'm aware of
with from exxon mobil exxon mobil gave
to everyone back in the day and they've
tried this it's a trick that they say
they'll say exxon mobil is given to
you know all these conservatives all
these climate denial groups and you'll
look at and they'll say they've given to
the heritage foundation they've given
the you know cato they give and a lot of
these have like five 10 15 percent of
their budget go to that but then you
look at it and exxon mobil gave to a lot
of liberal groups they gave a deal the
natural gas industry got gave money to
the sierra club so they could fight coal
money's like that all the way out there
but in terms of me being you know
courting fossil fuels or being a
spokesman for fossil fuels it's utter
nonsense they hate me they've hated me
they want nothing to do with me i went
time took a tour of fossil fuel guys
fossil fuel yeah because they're when i
say that they may have liked me in the
90s or something or maybe early 2000s
but that they they gave up about 2004 or
five long before i was even in the
senate exxonmobil announced they were no
longer giving to any groups expressing
climate you know denial or whatever so
here's the gist
they
stop giving money
and when they get when they stop giving
money they start they increase their
money the other side they just got a
grant uh it was from i want to say exxon
mobil gave to stanford university 100
million dollars to study climate change
another basic grant just came out the
largest single climate grant by an
internet billionaire and i can't
remember his name right now was no one
not a household name gave to another
university so the money from that side
and now from corporate from the fossil
fuel to appear green
far outweighs it so i don't like that
idea at all because i i basically my
salary hasn't even changed that much on
the same scale as it was when i worked
for the u.s taxpayer in the senate so
you could argue you mentioned rush
limbaugh you could argue i'm
ideologically motivated and i think
there's truth to that everyone has an
ideological motivation i think
particularly people involved in politics
but if you go back
i look at what happens if you could even
just remove the science forget about the
science and this is what i like to do to
your point about you don't want people
rush limbaugh was an entertainer and i
don't you know but i'm trying to i'm
trying to actually you know
let people see the other side to this
whole issue so one of the ways i do it
i just say to hell with talking about
the science for a moment if we actually
faced a crisis nothing they've proposed
in their own words by their own methods
would have any impact on the climate and
save us in other words if we were facing
a climate catastrophe and we relied on
them for the green new deal the u.n
paris agreement carbon taxes et cetera
we would all be doomed and i can go
through and i can point to you quotes
from united nations i can point you
quotes from the epa i can cite their
studies their magic they're called
acronym for magic for their climate
models that show that even if we fully
committed to all this there would be no
impact pretty much on co2 emissions let
alone the climate if you actually
believe co2 was causing it so
that's the way i like to go about it and
i again
they don't like me exxonmobil likes the
un paris agreement all the oil companies
support it they support carbon taxes
donald trump's first pick at secretary
of state was rex tillerson an absolute
disaster one of the first things he did
was didn't make any sense it made no
sense he goes to the arctic and signs on
some u.n climbing parties agreement greg
solison made no sense do you know who he
is he's big ceo yeah i mean yeah how do
you
that didn't make any sense but he wasn't
even it wasn't like climate skeptics
were oh he's great he was horrible the
exxon mobil
they will have nothing to do with anyone
they would never give to us because they
don't support our agenda at this point
big corporations support the woke agenda
20 years ago they were all
20 30 years ago the left hated big
corporations now
big corporations quake in the boots of
the left and the progressives and they
love them now so they're not with us
anymore and anyone who claims that oh
these climate denial groups are fossil
fuels explain
what you just said so
tell tell us why
why would exxon mobil
why would the left or exxon mobil
support the left that doesn't make any
sense because what they're saying the
green new deal
is there's no way in any shape or form
does a green new deal help an exxon
mobil's business model well
yes and no the more solar and wind we do
the more backup you need for fossil
fuels and it's who controls it there
were reports years ago of soros you know
groups buying a lot of the old coal
plants that were going out
or buying them and buying fossil fuels
to have them for backups because what's
going to happen here is exxon mobil
has the best lawyers has the best
lobbyists they can control the agenda so
they don't they're not afraid of massive
increases in regulation massive
government control because they
partially control the government it's
hard to tell in today's world whether
government is taking over corporations
or corporations are controlling the
government especially when you're
talking big pharma or you're talking you
know now even big oil or
um
and a whole range of these issues and
then you get into things you know with
the environment social governance the
chinese style credit scores of all these
companies where the boards are
infiltrated just like school boards were
with you know parents found that out
it's the same thing with these corporate
boards so that's one of the pressures
they have they want to look green to the
media and they also know that they can
handle it it crushes the smaller
competition
biggest success for american energy we
led the world in co2 reductions because
of fracking initially it was a lot of
smaller fracking operations and recent
years there's been consolidation and
taking over what's happening and it's
the same with you know when a lockdown
happens what happens small mom-and-pop
restaurants get crushed that's a
government designed you know uh planned
recession and they they've called for
that to fight climate change so that's
why big corporations support government
intrusion it gets rid of the small
competitors it allows consolidation
causes bankruptcy they can go in buy up
toxic assets why do you think blackrock
loves uh
economic chaos because they can then buy
real estate why does bill gates love
farmers having difficulty bill gates is
now the single largest farm owner in
america so it's a consolidation and all
of these government policies support
that consolidation and the ultimate one
was climate i noticed i'm talking past
tense climate in fact i lead a chapter
in my new book with a quote from richard
lindsen saying it's hard to imagine a
better leverage point for the control of
society than carbon dioxide humans
exhale carbon dioxide it's involved in
everything from plastic to all aspects
of our life to human energy economic
development long life
and human health
but they imagined it and that was a
virus scare and that's what they ended
up doing so that's how that happened but
essentially big business loves uh big
government at this point and that's why
exxon mobil would never support your
average climate skeptic now there might
be some you know
climate skeptics out there who you know
who who are lobbyists or something like
that but that's not in my world you know
i i trust my enemies a lot i trust them
a lot because i know my enemies have a
very uh honest outcome right they want
to eliminate you it's very they want to
eliminate you and they want to beat you
it's that so you have to trust your
enemies right in that context yes what
makes sense okay so if if we trust uh
our enemies and
we look at today what's going on in the
world who doesn't like america you may
have to put iran china and russia in
that group you know as of right now
those are the three countries this is
very you know fluid it changes sometimes
but as of right now those are the three
okay what what is from your experience
what's china's
russia's and iran's i'm talking ji i'm
not talking to people of china i'm
talking yes putin i'm talking at the top
what is their fear
and a paranoia
and handling of climate change how are
they strategizing to fight against
climate change are they putting any time
into it are they putting any resources
into it what are they doing okay i've
extensively studied russia and china a
little less clear on iran iran i don't
think you know cares that much about it
but they're the beneficiary we can start
with i mean iran
is the beneficiary of climate policy so
the more the west commits itself to
green new deal to net zero to build back
better we're going to be more reliant on
rogue regimes if you will like iran and
also like venezuela in terms of the way
russia and china china and russia are
the biggest beneficiaries of this entire
climate agenda at the moment it's
incredible
russian when uh price of gas
barrel goes above oil goes above 40
russia then starts getting uh funding
and it's a huge exponential increase
when it's below 40 a barrel
russia doesn't get extra money in their
coffers so what's happened is with our
shutting down europe and the united
states and canada of our domestic energy
remember europe is way ahead of us
they literally started shutting down
their fracking they stuck down their
coal price of electricity has been
skyrocketing across europe you have a
few bright spots in places like france
where they allow nuclear and support
nuclear but essentially
what they've done and you had uk prime
minister uh
what's boris johnson i always want to
say tony blair boris johnson in 2019
pouring concrete into fracking wells in
the uk as a virtue signal to how they
were going to be committed to net zero
climate goals
50 years of natural gas from these wells
poured cement over
now what happened during the 10 years
radical increase in reliance on russian
energy and that included germany or some
some countries i think germany is 40
near 50
all of europe is like 38 39 near 40
their reliance on vladimir putin's
russia why is russia able to do all this
because they're not following the
dictates of the united nations of they
don't have a domestic green new deal you
don't see putin putin will pay lip
service as needed
but it has been the greatest boon to
russian uh aggression russian national
interest
china
same it basically the same
premise china loves the premise of
the the once-free democratic west
shutting themselves down energy-wise and
doing what making us more reliant on
china 90 of our solar panels come from
there 90 of rare earth mining china has
cobalt mines in africa that amnesty
international 60 they own yeah kids as
young as nine allegedly doing slave
labor in china
and then at the same time you'll get
your starbucks mom or someone on the
america who's like oh i you we had to
buy only things that are certified and
ethical but at the same time they're
shutting down our domestic fossil fuels
which are the cleanest greatest
standards in the world because of
everything we've done
since the first earth day and i talked
in my powerpoint
to your point i think it was a very
important thing you said today
because rush limbaugh was an entertainer
and rush limbaugh
you know had a core audit but i and i do
come from that world where you know
essentially four years of this tv show
and i love rush limbaugh
but i'm trying now especially in this
post-covet age especially in the
censorship age where we gotta win people
over and i'm very excited when i see
people like naomi wolf and robert f
kennedy and jimmy dore and russell brand
who by the way russell brandt is my new
favorite number one favorite political
commentator probably followed by jimmy
dore
yeah he is but never even heard of the
guy pre-coveted i mean i heard of him as
an actor but not as i remember him as a
socialist or something being on fox news
and they were making anyway
i was sort of losing my train of thought
on that one uh you said you agree with
the point i made at the beginning that
oh yeah that i'm actually trying now
especially in the last two years since
limbaugh yeah to to be less divisive and
to actually i have a whole chapter in my
upcoming book
including all the progressives who agree
with us on tyranny i now believe it's no
longer a left-right political battle and
that went on for way too long it's now
basically tyranny versus freedom and we
welcome anyone on our side with that so
when i give presentations you know i'll
praise the first earth days because the
first earth they had a lot of wacky
elements a lot of ridiculous predictions
and
but
it essentially laid out a very big
concern about filthy rivers filthy air
um and just major environmental problems
that we had well we got the message and
it wasn't because of government
regulation it was because we made
ourselves aware and we had radical
improvements in human air quality human
water quality while at the same time
huge population increases in huge
economic growth we did it leading the
world essentially and so how it can be
done through innovation technology and
the more wealth you have the cleaner the
environment you have but back to china
my only thought final thing there is
china loves the climate agenda it makes
it we're going to get off american
energy independence and dominance which
beginning at covid 2020 we were the
world's largest oil and gas producer we
were we had more energy production than
consumption more energy exports than
imports for the first time since harry s
truman was president
and that of course toppled with covid
and then with biden coming in and you
know even further decimating fossil
fuels and that wasn't just executive
orders it was the defunding of it so
china is sitting pretty russia's sitting
pretty
and they'll always say climate change
causes more war no when you shut down
your domestic energy and you rely on
hostile regimes that's what causes more
conflict when now instead of relying on
american and canadian oil and europe
relying on their own oil and then
killing a pipeline for the east med
pipeline from israel to poland and
eastern europe
they've been relying on russia they can
be increasingly relying on china and
then of course the perverseness is they
do sanctions on putin we're going to
stick it to putin and that when you pay
more for gas you're sticking it to putin
all it's done is hurt american consumers
while putin sells his uh energy to i
totally get another country but that's
not where i'm going with it what i'm
going with it with is i
um paranoia reveals a ton right like if
if you can know what putin is afraid of
you'll know his next few moves right if
you know what g is afraid of you'll know
his next few moves if you really know
the real fear not the
fear that we think it is most of the
time it's hardest thing to know is the
real fear of the enemy but
how are they as a country that is overly
prepared in many areas china right how
are they fighting
and and what is the message from the top
there about climate change are they
treating you the same way we are are
they putting it as a top five crisis
that's you know we better be prepared
for it and spend billions of dollars if
not commit a few trillion dollars of our
resources the next decade or two to make
sure we can fight off climate change
what is their messaging with climate
change that's a good question because
it's a bit schizophrenic because on one
hand they're building they're 50 of the
world's coal production they're building
about one new coal plant a week in china
they're going through their industrial
revolution at the same time rhetorically
they will go to un climate uh agreements
which they have every annual meetings
every year yes part of the paris
agreement
and they get paid lip service why
because if you're making all the the
solar panels if you're making if you're
producing the rare earth mining and you
don't have the same environmental
standards you can produce it cheap and
get it out there and you know the more
the rest of the world signs on to the
climate agenda the more we're going to
be reliant on china you think that's
what it is i i truly it's in their
long-term strategic national so you
don't think the rest of the world is
becoming dependent no i do not think you
don't think they have any fear of
climate change i can't imagine that they
do at all do you think they don't have
any fear of climate change the way uh
the average person doesn't have any fear
and consequence of eating too much
cheesecaking too much food that's just
yeah i'm gonna live forever there's no
way i'm gonna have cancer there's no way
i'm gonna you know average person who
has a heart attack or a stroke or
something happens when they ate that
food or didn't exercise they weren't
thinking that it's ever gonna happen to
them it's always the other guy that's
gonna have cancer the other guy that's
gonna have a heart attack right so do
you think it's from that arrogant state
that oh you know we're gonna be powerful
forever or is it
we really think something's going on
let's do something about it no i think
if anything they would welcome
a a a climate nightmare or climate
emergency because it would create a
chaos you know if you listen to what the
climate models claim anybody you were
saying it would create a chaos that only
government could solve in their mind so
so they went either way
they benefit from the climate agenda
economically and long-term strategic
interest but they also benefit even if
the climate we're going to turn into the
apocalypse that al gore or the united
nations or celebrities predict because
chaos empowers the leadership in the
long-term goals of china then they can
control every aspect using the pretext
of a climate crisis same way they love
kobe they people hoped covert would be
bad i mean there are people whole
movements led by beginning with paul
ehrlich
particularly about the overpopulation
people wishing that viruses would kill
people off that the habitat the
habitable population of the earth is
only one billion so to answer your
question they win either way china's you
know in it for the long haul and
you know the whole thing with china too
if you go back to nafta it turns out
ross perot was right georgia h.w bush
was wrong al gore was wrong ross perot
was right about all the free trade
so-called free trade agreements because
that
shifted china from this you know old
country we should be helping and
developing world to now you know the
global superpower that probably there's
no turning back from at this point yeah
i'm uh go ahead no i mean uh with china
tyler if you want to pull this up
it's almost like you're saying don't
believe you're lying eyes i mean you see
the images that coming out of these
major cities in china
with the lockdowns you're talking about
no not with the lock
the smog and the pollution yeah so
anyone with
eyes can see this is what's going on in
major cities in china but that's so how
does that not that doesn't translate to
what you're saying that they don't care
about this they don't care about their
people they have 1.5 billion people
okay okay there's two explain that
there's air pollution and then there's
carbon dioxide okay and i think probably
from the beginning we should have laid
out like a science definition of all
this but
essentially they're going through their
industrialization but you're looking at
these pictures right now
is pittsburgh in 1885. it's uh you know
detroit it's uh new york city you know
this is this has happened during rapid
industrialization
when they sign on to the u.n paris
agreement they pledged essentially even
though they're ex they're pledged to
reach peak emissions i think was 20 30.
and that's when all the estimates said
that they were going to hit their p
commissions because they're going to
then level off and then they're going to
be able to start improving their
environment but they probably have
another decade or more of that kind of
filth in cities that's
traditional pollution
from sources carbon dioxide is we inhale
oxygen we exhale uh carbon dioxide as
humans
carbon dioxide is a trace essential gas
in the atmosphere that they're claiming
too much of will create a greenhouse
effect and cause this whole climate
emergency et cetera that's a little
different though that's a you know
you're saying there's a distinct
difference between pollution smog
grossness yes and actual co2 and actual
co2 which is what which is what they're
talking because when you see these
images whether it's in china or whether
it's in pittsburgh of
funnels of smoke and smog just leaving
pipelines into the air anyone with a
heart or mind will be like that's just
that's probably not good for the
environment absolutely and that's what
but that had but that's what they're go
they can't avoid that right now because
they're going through rapid insane
industrialization of economic growth but
just as are you saying that does nothing
to the environment that does nothing too
of course yeah yeah here's this is why i
want to start
in my opening of my powerpoint i showed
the world health organization actually
praises
uh there's the united states for one of
the cleanest air in the world i think
we're top seven or eight uh of the the
cleanest here we've it's great to hear
our top ten in something right we've
gone through that i'm talking about like
you know 100 years ago in the united
states and beyond 100 years but i'm
saying that is not to be don't conflate
climate with pollution that's what al
gore with climate pollution
we have a professor will happen the
foremost expert on the greenhouse effect
actually said that you know this is a
abuse of the english language to look at
you know pollution and smoke stack and
say that's you know that's carbon
dioxide and that's what's causing it's
not pollution co2 is probably the least
objectionable thing to come out of
industrial production yeah but china is
just so rapid right now and it's it's a
horrible it's horrible environmental
standards that's what's so incredible
and i mentioned the starbucks mom or the
starbucks liberal
you know they don't they don't want they
want to be all careful they want to buy
only stuff from certified forests all
this ethical buying and the whole
movement toward that but yet they have
no problem renewable energy and all the
rare earth mining and everything coming
from china and all the coal production
or anything that putin has been doing
people have just been accepting it
because
we're outsourcing our pollution
and carbon dioxide and when i say
outsourcing pollution is the more we
rely on energy from other countries
we're getting it from countries that
don't have the same environmental
standards as the u.s canada western
europe
russia iran china venezuela open do not
have the same you know technology and
focus on clean air and clean water let
me ask you and i'm sure we're going to
have way more of a nuanced debate or a
conversation
uh personal question uh you're married
yes you've got kids yes how old are your
kids
uh ranging from 11 to 20. okay so you
got kids and they're in that gen z range
of gen z has been indoctrinated that the
world is falling apart
on a personal level i mean even even
having conversations with their kids or
your kids friends on a personal level
how does it feel to you to know that
you're the guy that is
that's rooting for earth to
not win right like that this is this is
the argument
whether you call it the left that you're
the bad guy what did pat put it you're
one of the top five people who are
criminals against humanity yes so from a
personal level if i was branded a
criminal against humanity i'd have a
very strong like feedback or pushback on
that but explaining to your kids like
you don't want the earth to fail you
want us to live right yes
i'm for human flourishing then earth
prosperity and that's why i argue it's
about technology it's about wealth the
wealthier a country the cleaner the
environment it's that simple it
literally
you know there was a young south african
activist i interviewed at the earth
summit who sees like the rest of the
world is bs we need to be doing
everything the africa africa has it
right they're living in harmony with the
earth well are they really if you go if
one billion people don't have running
water and electricity asia south america
africa
they have
uh their use the rivers are sewage yeah
there's filth animal dung being burned
horrible air quality low life expectancy
slash and burn agriculture nothing about
it makes sense so i consider myself a
champion of the earth because we want to
use
everything from high-yield agriculture
to sustainable forestry to use that word
where you you know instead of doing
swash you cut areas you make it so it's
regenerative and as quickly as possible
we've done this incredible success story
on endangered species
rapid drop in species extinction since
1870 uh on every metric and there's you
know there's a there's there's a um
multiple reports one of the greatest
person on this is uh beyond lomberg who
runs the copenhagen consensus who goes
through all the ways in which planet
earth is bet is improving and how we can
improve it further and the way to do it
is technology wealth not a top-down
destruction of economic economic growth
so
i'm not against solar wind and renewable
energy per se but i'm against mandating
that energy and banning energy that's
proven itself so because one of the
greatest liberators of mankind has been
fossil fuels but beyond that it's been
also a liberator of the earth because we
have when you have people on earth and
you have
economic progress
you're gonna you're gonna if you're
using the old methods what save the
whale probably whale you know oil
oil from to use then in lamps instead of
whale oil i mean that was one of the
biggest things in coal
what saved uh you know what made our
cities radically cleaned up internal
combustion engine there were projections
in 1890 of every major city that horse
manure could be two two stories high in
new york city and other cities then what
happened the internal combustion engine
came along and basically had a massive
cleanup of all these cities in that
regard i mean there's always other
issues with but so i don't look at in
terms of my kids you know it's it's
funny because it people think like oh
the whole world thinks this way i live
in suburban virginia and
you know my kids have really
all their friends think they have the
same view there's very few that are all
worried i've very few kids are all
worried in my lifetime experience i've
even spoken at high schools and spoken
at their schools
um i want to stay on this topic with
china i want to say i appreciate that i
appreciate the question but i want to
stay on this topic can you refresh this
i want you to see this from 1960 where
china ranked on carbon emissions and how
it's grown
refresh again so people can't see it
eric i don't know if you guys put it
live or not so the audience can see it
i'll wait for you okay go for it so do
one more time do it one more time this
is where china
starts off yeah the u.s is still the
world's largest historic contributor of
co2 but china is now the biggest by far
and you'll see and john kerry's
referenced this he said even if the
united states and all the industrialized
world zero go down to zero it basically
won't make a difference in global
emissions because of china india these
other countries look how much russia
dropped off by the way then boom
that that acceleration in the 2000s with
china and how it went up and russia kept
going lower and lower and lower and
staying at 400. so refresh one more time
to see what happens from 1980 on
okay to see what happens from 1980 on so
look at russia's climbing
and then u.s has got a big lead and this
is not something you want to be leading
in this is co2 yeah this is co2 look at
russia's going up to five five seventy
five eighty five nine six hundred six
forty six forty five six sixteen and six
eighty and then look at russia drops so
what did russia do to drop and what did
china do
to increase from 2000 1995
to today okay great question
what did russia do russia collapsed what
a great way you you collapsed your
entire economy in all the eastern
satellite same thing happened in eastern
europe you're going to lower your
emissions but you're also going to have
eo misery but you just said the more
wealth there is the better it is right
you
you you just well that's
under a communist system they didn't
have
russia had a huge increase until what
because 1989 where berlin approached
again 91
and then it collapses but then all
industrial activity stops so i don't
i'm not talking about co2 i'm talking
about environment when i say huge
engineering okay yeah yeah yeah but even
environment i mean the us because we did
we switched from coal to fracking
natural gas fracking and that's why ours
chiefly dropped dramatically defied
every energy prediction in 2010. but i'm
talking when i specifically said wealth
it's greener environment overall but
also co2 but but russia has nothing
going for it they had a centralized
communist system then they collapsed and
then now they're under an autocratic
dictatorship i mean they just have it's
not even a country that would apply to
the same standards anyway in terms of
that well china you asked what happened
i can talk about china in a second but
go for it i want to hear about china
that's all i was going to ask about well
china as i mentioned earlier ross perot
was right in the late night all these
free trade agreements and all of the uh
uh from from nafta the world trade
organization
literally allowed and i i blame a lot of
the doctrinaire free-market
conservatives as well libertarians who
always said it's
if you can get your product cheap you
buy your product from the cheapest place
doesn't matter where those people who
buy american is nonsense
that would work in a world where the
people you're buying it from
aren't don't have an agenda to basically
crush you and use it again fully agree
and
williams and i always i was always
saying i wish he was still alive he died
about a year or two ago economist walter
williams and george mason i um
and i knew him i interviewed him and uh
i wish i could have you know in later
years asked him about that because to me
that's what happened is we
gave away our industrial base through
these agreements to not just china but
also india we transferred not just
remember i said outsourcing pollution
outsourcing we outsourced our wealth our
job creation and our industries to these
countries under the guise of free trade
because they were always going to beat
us under cheaper and now what we're
facing is china is essentially can can
rule the world in fact they when they do
stuff like lockdowns and we all follow
when they control the world health
organization along with bill gates it's
incredible how powerful they are but
economically unbelievably powerful all
the supply chain issues we are so
reliant on them now and i think we're
just waking up to what we've done under
republican presidents
chiefly i would say and and some and
democrats as well uh with all these free
trade and uh call it free trade in
quotes but that was the huge economic
transfer can you go a little bit china's
booming watch this if you go a little
older this is a great article about it
we call little lore
uh challenging which is like them to me
to climate targets that they have we
keep going lower to the coal charts
uh china continues to rely heavily on
coal which is what you just talked about
energy consumption in china by source
you see where they're at look at that
from 65 till today what it looks like
which is insane and then she on the
bottom makes a
prediction about what they're going to
do with coal go little or right there
make it a little bit bigger president xi
says china will face down
coal use from 2026 and will not build
new coal-fired project abroad
but some governments and company
campaigners say the plans are not going
far enough researchers at
uh chingua uh university in beijing
china will need to stop using coal
entirely for generating electricity by
2050 to be replaced by nuclear renewable
energy production so okay so that's this
part now on can you pull up the other
two charts that musk put up the two
pictures so here's what musk was
explaining and i want to really kind of
get your feeling on this what does this
mean to the average person that's
watching this so here is what co2 looks
like from 1960 to 2015 right
and this is part of the speech that musk
gave you look at this some the average
person is going to be like well that's
not really a big deal but when you zoom
out and you look at it from a thousand
till 2015 that's what it looks like okay
how this has grown in that time period
so
this anybody that looks at this will say
this is deeply concerning on the growth
that we had from whatever 1950s till
today can you unpack this please yes uh
do you want to go to my powerpoint
beginning of my powerpoint i actually
have this same chart i think from al
gore's movie basically uh go uh
keep going keep going keep going right
there
zoom in on that
that's basically the same chart the
second yellow where al gore is is where
his projections are but i believe the
chart you just showed is where that
first yellow dot is that's what that's
looks intimidating a couple things there
that's ice core data from antarctica and
it's co2 in temperature the red is the
co2 but what gore doesn't mention is
that the temperature
leads the co2 so as the temperature goes
up the oceans emit more co2 he makes you
think that co2 then drives the
temperature that's point one
which is a technical point and even his
producer in a children's book reversed
that and said that you know co2 leads
temperature when it's the reverse now go
to the next slide
and that's if you look back further in
the geologic record there you're going
back uh you know millions of years
that's al gore's high point and this is
a key point here and this is in uh
but when you talk to us how many years
back is this this is going back five 700
million years or so i believe that who
gets data from 700 million years ago how
do you do that uh it's based on all
sorts of uh you know basically
data from everything from sediments lake
bed rocks um people have a hard time
believing a book came out two thousand
years ago called the bible and jesus let
alone seven hundred million years ago
they could be off on the year i don't
even know if they are often they're
pretty confident in it but that's a
different argument you know you're
talking about young earthquakes i wonder
if they use excel back in the days like
but here's the key 90 of earth's
geologic history had co2 levels
uh higher than today and ninety percent
of earth's geologic history was warmer
than today we're in the ten percent
coldest ten percent lowest co2 where
actually we've had scientists testify to
congress that we were in a co2 famine so
if you look at it the earth has been 90
of history has been too warm to have ice
at either pole we're in the 10 coldest
part so what gore is showing you is a
little snippet of earth's geologic
history
uh now go to the next slide what do i
have i think
this is according to noah this is an
actual chart and the biden
administration's up up on their website
showing earth's history much hotter than
today and this is a quote from the noaa
website past temperatures much too warm
for ice sheets or piranhas exactly what
i'm saying and they go back 500 million
years now you could argue about that and
you know but that you know if you're
going to accept the other science you
get you look at this i agree and you see
that you see the blue chart that's today
that's an idea now if you go again i
think i have the u.n chart but i don't
know that i do yes this was in the first
united nations report in 1990. look at
the medieval war period showed it as
warmer than today this is important
because this is what elon musk is using
and what you brought up
we had a scientist named david deming
university of oklahoma come testify
before the united states senate
environment committee
in that after that 1990 u.n report which
this chart was featured in the ipcc
intergovernmental panel on climate
change
the gold standard if you will that the
un scientists started an email campaign
and started contacting we have to get
rid of the medieval warm period why
would a climate activist scientists
chosen and to work with the united
nations want to get rid of the medieval
warm period well because if current
temperatures are not as warm as a
medieval warm period it's hard to scare
the public about it so that led to the
whole creation of the hockey stick which
was done by penn state professor michael
mann who just recently moved to
university of pennsylvania which was
called statistical rubbish he went
through and used
all sorts of proxy data for climate and
he smoothed out the medieval warm period
he smoothed out
this is just the northern hemisphere
because we don't have real good data for
the southern hemisphere but he smoothed
out the little ice age and he made a
hockey stick meaning the 20th century
showed this great big temperature these
are temperatures not co2 this chart
this was critical because people
need to know that when originally the un
report
the science hasn't changed in the past
you could argue our understanding of it
but then you get into what they did the
lobbying campaign the professors
received an email saying we have to get
rid of the medieval warm period lo and
behold they got rid of it a few years
later with a very controversial chart
that has been roundly attacked even by
people who believe in a climate you know
climate is a huge problem
discredit it and even man michael mann's
own colleagues in the un uh climate gate
emails revealed it so go to the next
thing i don't know if i have any other
chart here
actually this is another this is a chart
exaggerating global temperatures in 1880
we always hear this is done by the
greenpeace co-founder patrick moore
who's now a big climate dissenter if you
will
but that's showing you the the global
temperature and i believe that's you
know tenths or half a degree
the key here is when they claim that
things have gone skyrocketing or
unprecedented the hottest year on record
the hottest decade
it's with tenths
hundredths of a degree
not even measurable it's within the
margin of error within the margin that
they adjust the temperatures it's a
fancy way for them to say you know 2006
the hottest year on record but it's not
statistically different from 2005 or
even sometimes it was 1998 so
essentially it turns into the last 25
years we haven't had since
late 90s
we had very little warming but then if
you go back to the 1970s where they
start a lot of the baselines we've had a
lot more warning because that was a
little ice age if you keep going i
believe i have an epa chart just one
other point on since we're doing charts
keep going a little faster uh
more and more
keep going you'll see it you'll see a
temperature chart uh that's tipping
point well
well that's actually let's stop there
that's a good one there this is i'll
stop here
this is a co2 chart that shows you since
1960 the same chart but here's the other
thing and this is what i focus on these
are u.n meetings the u.n earth summit
1992 you see rio berlin there's kyoto
1997. if you go up you can see paris
that's 2015. you can see the lockdown
everything they've talked about
everything they've tried has failed to
reduce co2 emissions it's all window
dressing it's a fancy way of saying
we need to convert to a technocratic
socialist
system in order to control the climate
because
this because capitalism will destroy the
environment but nothing they've done or
attempted to do has had any impact and
roy spencer a climatologist formerly
with nasa said it would take about a 50
reduction in co2 total emissions for at
least a year or more to actually make a
dent in that kind of a chart so go to
the green new deal what the green new
deal
uh uh is not a bill it's something that
you know it was 14 pages what it what
are they proposing is their solution for
it so because to me everything fine
let's just say this is happening what's
your solution what's your approach to
fixing this the green new deal the green
new deal looks at this and it goes back
to what i just said they believe that
the earth can't handle capitalism
essentially and freedom and that we need
to have a socialist system but they know
they could never sell their brand of
socialism i don't know if it's the right
terms anymore especially since covet
it's not really socialism you could you
could argue it's technocracy it's uh
it's a tyranny of uh you know
of uh the of a small elite group of
people but essentially
the green new deal argues
that
that they can't sell their ideas on
their own so they argued that we have a
crisis and that this is the solution in
other words if they had to sell the
green new deal on its own merits it
would have no chance so they use the
climate scare to say this is what's
happening with the climate scare and
these are our solutions and the
solutions what is these what is these
it's solutions okay in my book green
fraud i have a whole chapter on the
1970s ice age scare and it's eerie how
the green new deal literally mirrors the
same solutions to the ice age scare
sovereignty limiting treaties economic
de-growth uh stopping of meat stock
radical restrictions on freedom of
movement
uh radical restrictions on home
ownership radical restrictions on just
on
on thermostat controls in your house on
the size of your home in other words
it's a microregulation
of every aspect of your life they did
this in the 1970s first of all they said
that man-made global cooling
was caused by fossil fuels emitting
aerosols which were blocking the sun
causing global dimming their solutions
were sovereignty limited treating wealth
redistribution uh and and literally the
the same
virtual signaling of the climate in
other words it's the same agenda you can
go back to the overpopulation you can go
back to the the rainforest scares
whatever environmental problem they
always believe the government needs to
step in and micromanage all of freedom
every aspect of our life because people
left alone
will create environmental disasters
racial disasters will create climate
disasters and we need government to
essentially keep a watch over on us and
that's why the green new deal does
everything from your dishwasher to your
washing machine to your control your
home thermostat to your to your
to your diet to your travel to the type
of homes you can buy whether they're
sustainable to the type of car to
eliminating the internal combustion
engine which is gaining
that's a huge issue that's gaining huge
steam but all of this was part of the
green new deal as a framework
importantly though they introduced the
green new deal
multiple times but most recently when
biden was first elected when he was
sworn in and you never heard of it again
why is that because they know even
democrats won't support it it's the same
way democrats didn't support obama's cap
and trade force is not going to work for
force is not going to work and as much
as they want to do it can you pull up
this article from northwestern uh
education.edu the one i just text you
yeah can you make this bigger so i just
pulled up to see what are ways to
stop global warming okay let's see what
they have number one change of light
replacing one regular light bulb with a
compact fluorescent light bulb will save
you 150 pounds of carbon dioxide a year
number two drive less walk by carpool or
take mass transits more often number
three recycle more you can save 2 400
pounds of carbon dioxide per year by
recycling just half of your household
waste number four check your tires
keeping your tires inflated properly can
reduce your gas mileage by more than
three percent every gallon okay so far
nothing is forced i'm okay with any of
these so far yeah use less hot water it
takes a lot of okay fine avoid products
with a lot of packages
you know okay fine adjust your
thermostat move your thermostat down
just two degrees in winter and up two
degrees in summer could save you two
thousand pounds of carbon dioxide a year
okay whatever plant a tree single tree
can will absorb one
ton of carbon dioxide over its lifetime
and last one turn off electric
electronic devices simply turning off
your television individuals oh cool i
find dvd player that's what we used to
watch it's the same list they would have
given you in the 1970s during but what
i'm saying is the following okay
bill nye said the year i was born
america the world had 2.99 billion
people living there 3 billion people
living there today it's at seven and a
half billion people okay
so then you go and you say everything's
linked to
the
growth of population seven and a half
billion people okay then you'll hear the
word being thrown thrown around where
even gate said this in 2011 i want to
say cnn when he was talking to is it
gupta not group they was talking to the
doctor that was on joe rogan what's the
guy that's
okay yeah yeah he's talking to gupta
they're talking about you know
depopulation right okay so if they're
saying the problem is
really serious okay so
you know so then the solution becomes
you need to go from seven and a half
billion eight billion back to one
billion so what do you want to do about
it do you really want to fix it that way
because that seems to be the only
solution because what okay so then let's
let's just say you can't have that many
babies you know you know like china deal
and china went back to the one baby deal
and now they're back down to back up to
like listen we need to have some babies
because we've slowed down and average
age is now 38.4 and we got india's at
26. we got to compete we got old people
we got to have more babies so what is
really the solution because the solution
i'm hearing about
is either more control
you know at least you look at what
tesla's doing what what elon musk is
doing right credit to him by the way to
give him credit on what he said even
though he said that six years ago the
video i played the the what i read about
what he said yeah he said this october
18th of 2021 what i'm about to read to
you he said if you ask any scientist
are you sure that human activity is
causing global warming
any scientist should say no
this is elon musk because you cannot be
sure
let's say hypothetically co2 was good
for the environment and let's say
hypothetically the united states
possessed all the oil in the world well
you'd still have to get off oil because
it's a it's a finite resource and as you
start to run out of it the scarcity
would drive the cost up and cause
economic collapse it's just i just don't
understand why we'd run that experiment
particularly when at you when you
considered that at some point we have to
get to something that is sustainable we
have to have sustainable production of
energy and consumption of energy because
uh tautology tautologically
it is is that the word by the way
how do you what does that word mean by
the way it's it's like
you guys are using big
esl over here right tell me what that do
you know what that word is that earlier
it's like a double meaning topologically
it's redundant okay because
tautologically if it's unsustainable you
will run out of it so even he is saying
that's that's a that was that's a that's
a shift
seven months ago
the first part of that yeah the second
part okay
i in the book i detail in my research i
went back johnny carson's show is a
great source for people like paul
ehrlich who was a celebrity he was like
the al gore of his day on overpopulation
well in 1980
well first of all in the 1960s he warned
of the same thing peak oil resource
scarcity we're going to have famines
we're going to have massive population
uh disruption because we're going to run
out of all these fuels he lamented
people hopping in their car driving to
the grocery store getting a six-pack
this is all paul ehrlich he predicted
the end of oil within 10 years in 1980.
there's been people predicting the end
of oil for decades i think it's at least
since the 1930s 40s maybe earlier
the problem with what elon musk said and
there's not i mean
if
if solar wind first of all solar and
wind last count 2020 are less than four
percent of the u.s energy production
we're still about 79 fossil fuels if you
go back 100 years we're about 80 fossils
same with global not much has changed
so
there is no chance people thought we
were going to run out of natural gas or
didn't think natural gas was that
plentiful where is it we can't get it we
found a new way or they revised and they
improved upon an old way fracking
hydraulic fracking we ended up in that
this is in my book i think it was 2009
energy information agency made
projections not a single prediction was
right about the trajectory of co2
emissions because the united states led
the world in our reduction that little
chart the little video animation you
showed showed our rapid and that was
because we switched from coal to natural
gas
a better technique was able to extract
it so there's no way people
can predict that when fossil fuel will
run out having said that
when you're powering a modern economy
you don't ban energy that's plentiful
now and available and there's probably
who knows with new technology
oil and gas could go for
thousands of years hundreds of years who
knows how many years but you always know
100 years ago
200 years ago technology's always
changing you can never predict the
energy mix the problem with the whole
climate agenda problem with what elon
musk said
he's trying to use subsidies government
regulations and bans on certain
industries and to promote some and ban
others which means you're going to be
shutting down one and forcing us to go
to another they're going after the
internal combustion engine the world
bank
nicholas stern former president at world
bank meeting a couple weeks ago wants to
stop the world bank financing of
institutions organizations 2030 2035.
that's huge yes i mean you can't like
that you can't just say oh yeah i'm not
gonna give up my suv you're not gonna
have a choice when chrysler ford and all
the automakers aren't gonna be able to
get financing to even make it that's
point one but then point two of course
and this is where i still waiting for
the woke uh i shouldn't say woke but the
the newly woke to skepticism uh both i'm
waiting for rfk junior and elon musk to
come out and address this
naomi wolfe already has she's condemned
the green new deal as fascist uh but i'm
waiting to hear rfk junior and elon musk
start condemning some of their previous
positions on climate they haven't done
it but i do i do sense a shift in elon
musk but essentially
you use what you have until you have
something to replace it and that's the
biggest complaint when people can go to
walmart and buy a solar panel put it on
the roof and get off the grid that's the
day you don't need to have this silly
argument but in the meantime you're
allowing bureaucratic bean counters
politicians lobbyists and big
corporations to determine every aspect
and say we got to get rid of this this
kind of car your dishwasher's gonna have
to run for three hours we're gonna have
a thermostat control on your home
because we don't want you to you know
put the air conditioner too high we're
gonna have carbon ration cars and then
you get into this whole
post covert dystopian world which i'd
like to talk about we'd like to talk
about at some point because that's
changed the entire climate debate it's a
quaint discussion to sit here and talk
about the green new deal it's really
irrelevant at this point it's probably
never going to be voted on in congress
it's being implemented as we speak
in every agency of the biden
administration through financing through
the bureaucracy through executive orders
but more importantly climate is no
longer the issue it was it is now a
literally they uh it's been it's been
consumed by covid climate is a
supporting player now you uncheck
climate change leads to unchecked covid
if you don't support green new deal
you're a grandma killer but it's all
about climate causing more uh covert
sorry climate causing more viruses
because people don't care
they tried for decades to get people
scared on climate they failed according
to pew harris
gallup polling a virus comes along cut
across ideological lines terrified them
and then the climate activists said
everything we're doing for covid we
should have been doing for climate and
now harvard public health journal nature
they're all saying
uncheck climate change leads to more
viruses so covet is now
consumed climate and what's wrong
according to what's wrong with uh having
a hundred percent of cars being evs
the problem with that okay a couple
there's first of all what's wrong with
that here's what's wrong with it bride
administration right now is trying to
build a national charging station
powered by the government and funded by
the government and all over the
the problem with that is henry ford
didn't envision a nationalized gas
system what does that mean
if you have a ban the internal
combustion engine and then you only have
a national especially a power train or
you have to plug in your house which is
going to be huge uh electricity bill
increase you're going to have the
government will have the power to turn
off this electricity number one they can
stop movement but more importantly when
you're plugging in and charging your ev
not only are you relying more on china
for all the rare earth mining the cobalt
and for other components but you're also
literally
charging your car currently on 40 50 80
fossil fuels say it's a coal car it's a
natural gas car it's an oil car
depending on where you live and what
your local generation is so it's just
kind of it's a weird nonsensical
transfer people think oh i have an
electric car i don't need fossil fuels
i'm sorry and how are you plugging it in
where's the energy michael moore laid
this out brilliantly
and planted the humans he said oh
everyone's for solar and wind electric
cars but where's that energy coming from
and he would show like the solar panel
displays they'd pull the curtain back
like in the wizard of oz and show the
diesel generators running the power as
backup behind the scenes so
uh but an electric car
if you want to get one fine i personally
will never buy one because i drive stick
shift until they come up with at least a
faux stick shift in an electric car i
have no interest in it but there's
nothing wrong with an electric car i
know people have teslas they love them
in that regard but don't try to sell
them as planet saving and don't mandate
it and don't use them to get rid of you
know internal combustion cars but beyond
that
a huge number of government reports
academic u.s information agency all
these reports coming out calling for the
abolition of private car ownership which
is where i think this is ultimately
going to go andrew yang the democrat
president i believe you interviewed him
uh like
three weeks ago four weeks ago oh okay
he actually during the campaign when
he's running for president said he wants
to
possibly look at eliminating private car
ownership and instead turning to roving
fleet of rental electric cars for people
that is where i think they want to go
with this in an electric car because and
there's also reports and i haven't been
able to verify this but that elon musk
should try to de-power or turn off the
his cars that are in russia as a
punishment to the russian citizens for
living under putin
but the idea that you you have to pay a
subscription for certain elements for
certainly the self-driving parts of
tesla you're getting into this corporate
government merger where your life's
going to be more dependent one of the
things that the automobile i.e the
internal combustion engine gave
americans was freedom the freedom to
move freedom of movement freedom to
drive same way with cheap air travel
they're they're going after that hard
under a declared climate emergency you
can only fly when it's morally
justifiable uh you can in france are
already eliminating short-haul flights
due to co2
in
the united states they are they are
literally talking about flying once or
twice a year and all these government
reports and i detail them these are in
peer-reviewed journal these are in
academic reports
it's very clear where they want to go
with this so they've got this thread of
co2 and they're using it for everything
the same way they used the threat of a
virus to shut down
churches and backyard barbecues and
weddings and funerals but hey walmart
was open and hey amazon was making a lot
of money and hey go on online and
facebook
this is part of their agenda they need
crises and that's
it's about crisis declaration if you go
back in history the roman republic
descended into an empire from abuse of
emergency powers middle ages saw
centralization of power germany 1933 the
abuse of emergency powers the patriot
act abuse of emergency powers which
essentially is leading to all the
banning of
free speech today
but this is the world we face now they
want to declare a national climate
emergency they want to have a pandemic
treaty which is the most frightening
thing modeled after this u.n climate
ipcc report that's where we're headed
right now
with the coveted climate you know
merging of issues and bill gates's ex
bill gates is calling it germ bill gates
single biggest funder to world health
organization they want a pandemic treaty
where bill gates paid experts can
declare a viral emergency
shut down essentially the world in a
whim you can get rid of your outliers
like sweden or
ron desantis make us all beholden to
some global treaty where we have to go
on it that's what's scary they tried for
decades on climate utterly failed that's
why they went after kids the whole greta
thunberg movement was the climate's
activist realization that they failed to
convince adults so they went after kids
and they did a pretty good job with kids
to scare them
you know a part of this when it comes
down to climate change i have a hard
time fully buying it's that big of a
threat
um and it's such a title we can hear you
and it's such a different angle on why i
have a hard time believing it is i'm in
the insurance business okay
the insurance business these are
capitalists okay yes these are
capitalists that don't like to lose
capital the reason why life insurance
business has the tallest skyscrapers in
top 20 metropolitan cities and you'll
see metlife you'll see new york live
you'll see all these other companies
it's because they don't lose money
that's why life insurance companies have
so much money so why don't they lose any
money
because they have the best and brightest
minds actuaries who sit there and they
look up data all day long and that's
what they do for a living and what kind
of data are they really looking for
they're looking for data to see when you
and i are expected to die and then they
insure us and they underwrite us right
try calling and people say well no that
doesn't matter the insurance companies
will underwrite anybody [ __ ] yeah i
i can tell you personally our company
we've sold nearly 500 000 insurance
policies the last 13 years right give or
take
and i can tell you how many times i've
had to call a carrier and say hey this
person is now their table d and all
their table this no they're not going to
get approved no no no we're not going to
prove this but it's a big premium i'm
sorry we can't approve this person
because it's a risk right okay so why
are they you know selling life insurance
to 20 year olds and they're giving them
a million dollars to pay 50 bucks a
month because they're expecting that 20
year old to live 100 years and if that
20 year old is going to live a hundred
years that means the next eight years
nothing's going to happen so that 2050
the end of the world coming if it's so
bad
why are insurance companies underwriting
trillions of dollars of paper yeah why
are they doing it so my mine is more of
a logical
mathematical where the capitalist is not
going to give up money for the hell of
it because it doesn't help them out so
the moment folks if you really want to
know like here's what i'll tell you
if the market's doing well if the
market's doing bad if you want to know
if the market's doing bad look at
annuity sales
when annuity sales goes up it'll tell
you if people are afraid or not okay
when annuity sales goes up when people
start buying annuities and they start
buying insurance against things
happening people are afraid meaning
there's a you know downturn coming okay
if people stop going to vegas and
gambling there's issues going on if
people stop buying and gambling with
nfts they're afraid something's going on
right because that's part of a gamble
it's a new thing and ft's that's going
on right
so if you ever see
cost of life insurance go up
and
actuaries all of a sudden 3x the cost of
life insurance you best believe these
insurance companies know something we
don't know they have the best lobbyists
they have the best
you know people that they hire that are
sitting there wondering whether they can
protect their hedge against a risk
long-term or not so as much as i hear
both sides of the argument i just go
back to logic and say if it's such a big
threat
why is 100
of all life insurance companies
still using the same formula as
actuaries to underwrite clients why if
the world is coming to an end why are
they not so worried about it well i
think they're looking at the data in
fact
part of the covet climate merging is
a doctor in canada in a new group
doctors group is now diagnosing patients
with climate change as suffering from
climate change a woman in canada the
head of the er department of a major
hospital in british columbia canada
diagnosed her as having climate change
what does that even mean it means she
was suffering from heat exhaustion so
she's suffering the effects so they want
to make it a clinical diagnosis world
health organization said climate is the
greatest are you being serious about
pull up the story a canadian doctor has
diagnosed a woman with climate change
after she came to hospital breathing
problems dr cal merritt
came to the unprecedented conclusion
after finding that a recent
heat wave and poor air quality in nelson
british columbia contributed to
seven-year-olds deteriorating health
this is
just like hypochondria is that what this
is well this is they're making up a
problem this is important it's a legal
thing the world health 2018 pre-covert
climate is the greatest public health
threat we face bill gates has said
publicly covet is going to have climate
is going to cover more people than covet
following up directly on this
adding climate change as a cause of
death to death certificates this is
important
this will give us a daily annual monthly
weekly death count of climate deaths
related deaths they want to put this as
a cause of death contributing factor the
reason i'm bringing all this up is
because you're talking about insurance
and you're talking about actuaries and
everything else well if you look at it
and i think what these underwriters
you're referring to are looking at
if you go back 100 years you know what
the climate-related death rate for
americans i think was global has dropped
99
death rate drop from affected by heat
cold storms you know hurricanes floods
droughts you name it and that's chiefly
because of better technology and better
infrastructure due to fossil fuels the
death rate from climate has dropped 99
so i think the insurance actuaries are
looking at that to use if you want to
find about a death certificate that's
pretty interesting too but that's in my
powerpoint toward the end where you
could just go to my website and look up
that certificate of this person no it's
a whole nother group of australian
academics want to add climate as a cause
of death to death certificates that was
done first and then they're diagnosing
patients with climate change second
but here's the bottom line if you are
worried about climate it's like people
always say john kerry is always famous
but that's that's what could happen
they're going to replace covet is this
if you actually uh
what does this one say yeah death
certificate's coming
uh yeah i mean you could even even play
my murano minute there if you wanted but
but anyway
if you have a situation where people are
looking at the at the
climate situation and they say john
kerry will say well we need an insurance
policy in case the climate deniers are
wrong would you buy a premium on your
home that cost more than the home and
paid out absolutely nothing if your home
burned down because that's what they're
selling and john kerry admits that at
different times but even if we zero our
missions out it wouldn't even affect
global emissions let alone theoretically
the climate in some way
so i always say no one would ever buy a
policy like that that's part of the
reason the green new deal the u.n pairs
none of this makes sense even if every
nation does what they want were
committed to in the u.n paris agreement
within by the year 2100 you wouldn't
even notice a barely detectable
temperature change slightly cooler
according to the u.n within like tenths
or hundredths of a degree not even
measurable by any way shape or form and
that's using their own data and the same
goes with the green new deal and
everything so it's just a it's a it's a
misdirection they're scaring you with
climate and they come up with a solution
that if you actually face the climate
crisis would have no solution and that
goes to yeah calls to add climate change
to death certificates australian
national university
take this seriously because they're
talking about making it a public health
threat 230 medical journals anthony
fauci has said that covid was a result
of our not mastering nature that human
beings have to now master nature it's
all about control they want to control
every aspect of human endeavor this
these are the new fascists these are the
new
tyranny they're using climate covert any
kind of crisis they can declare an
emergency they become all-powerful
that's literally what we're facing and
that is why i think the eye-opener for
elon musk and naomi wolf jimmy dore
russell brand and a whole host bill
maher i mean look look at bill maher i
mean it's it's shocking uh his
transformation on and once you start
there's no way someone like robert f
kennedy bill maher can talk about covid
the exaggeration the lies and the
so-called solutions and the tyranny and
then not
say oh but climate change and then say
climate change is real it would make no
sense once you see the light and once
you express it i'd love someone and i've
not heard it and i've even talked to
people
in research robert f kennedy jr talking
about climate recently how i don't know
i don't know of his position does he
support the green new deal does he
support a um paris agreement because
it's the exact same solutions there's a
book in the 80s called everything i knew
everything i learned i learned in
kindergarten it was a famous pop culture
book well everything i learned about
covet i learned during the climate
debate you come up with a scary
prediction based on faulty models and
you say this is what's going to happen
catastrophe and we need this draconian
solution they did it for climate no one
paid attention they did it for covid
everyone listened to neil ferguson
including pathetically president donald
trump who signed that emergency
declaration in march of 2020 who
empowered the fouchy at all the lowest
point of the trump administration was
larry kudlow being asked i think of a
cnbc when is the economy going to open
back up and he's like oh i don't know
that's up to the health people
literally the president of the united
states ceded our
united states economy they're probably
the greatest economy we've had in 50
plus years lowest black and
to the public health people to larry
kudlow the the brilliant econo economist
you even fell prey to this and that was
you know that was how this happened and
that emboldened if a republican
conservative president could fall for
this this is where the climate activists
began to pounce and you'll see in the
green fraud book and in my new book
multiple chapters just on how the greens
the climate activists praised the
coveted lockdowns
said john kerry himself said it's the
same thing as the parallels are
screaming at us between covet and
climate jane fonda said covert was god's
gift to the left it gave him everything
they wanted and that's
that's the scary part that's where we
are right now uh in this world jane
fonda said climate change is god's give
to the life covet was god's gift to the
left covet in part because it gave them
their agenda in part i guess because it
helped defeat donald trump you can look
that up uh look up jane fonda covet
god's gift to left
[Music]
but this is this is the world which
we're facing and i still can't believe
um
republican i mean i spent all most of my
time these days just bashing republicans
on climate and coveted jane fonda calls
coronavirus god's give to the left yeah
uh two years ago can you go to the neil
uh the grace tyson article okay so so
degrasse tyson says it might be too late
to recover from climate change this is
the one where we had an emotional this
is five years ago or something can you
go a little lower to read it on how he
puts it make it a little bit bigger so i
can read it so neil tyson neil degra the
grass ends up some of the devastating
floods and hurricanes and we're going to
make it a little bit small okay there
you go in an interview with cnn gps
tyson got emotional when fareed zakari
asked about what made homeland security
adviser thomas refusal to say what the
climate change has been a factor in
hurricane harvey or irma's strength
despite scientific evidence pointing to
the fact that it had made the storms
more destructive 50 inches of rain in
houston tyson claimed this is a shot
across our bow hurricane the width of
florida going up the center of florida
what will it take for people to
recognize that a community of scientists
are learning objective truths about the
natural world and that you can benefit
from knowing about it and he continued
to say uh that he had no patience for
those who as he puts it cherry-pick
scientific studies according to their
belief system the press will sometimes
find a singular paper single paper and
say oh there's a new truth if the study
holds it but an
emergent scientific truth for it to
become an objective truth the truth that
is true whatever whether or not you
believe in it it requires more than one
scientific paper requires a whole system
of people research all leaning in the
same direction all pointing to the same
kind anyways so he goes on you know
saying the two uh the day two
politicians are arguing about whether
science is true it means nothing gets
done nothing it's the beginning of the
end of an informed democracy as i've
said it many times
what do you think about when you're this
is this is considered to many people one
of the smartest guys in america okay so
some people this guy's got billions on
top of billions of views okay
adults
kids watch us content they're taught by
by many teachers if he's saying
something like this the average person
says right needle has to be smarter than
you mark to say something and they said
the same thing about anthony fauci when
he first came out
this is what you call science by expert
decree he comes out with this he does it
passionately he's a science spokesman
for decisions that have essentially
already been made he's a science
lobbyist and that's what i call the
united nations climate panel this is a
group of people who are self-selected
who join up and they try to make the
report we have multiple u.n headsets
wait on the next report they'll be so
alarming the world will have to act so
what he's saying first of all what he's
saying about hurricanes it's not first
of all it's not about well this new
study oh skeptics are right we have a
paper in our hand
it's about data and it's about the
complete picture what ends up happening
on climate alarm and he's talking about
a hurricane the width of florida when
current reality fails to alarm you make
up scary predictions of the future
and if you look at this first of all on
all weather hurricanes floods droughts
tornadoes wildfires there's either no
trend or declining trend and this is
sourced from united nations reports and
there's no way the worst hurricane
decade of the last hundred years was the
1940s the u.n has done multiple extreme
weather reports where they bury this
information but essentially shows
there's either no trend global droughts
there's no trend
global floods there's no trend
but they scare you because they predict
it's going to happen and then he
mentioned houston having 50 inches of
water or whatever it was
the whole nature of extreme weather is
you can always find some extreme
somewhere there's always going to be a
record broken
liking it to a lottery
the odds of you winning the lottery are
low the odds of someone winning the
lottery are almost 100 at some point or
maybe some weeks they don't if they're
doing a pick six or something but that
what his job is is to highlight the
lottery winners and make it look like
everyone's winning in this case he's
highlighting one city with 50 inches of
rain and making it look like that's
happening globally when in reality it's
not global floods so if you look at the
actual trends of all the underlying data
it's not there and by the way i'm seeing
sea level go by here sea level's been
rising since 20 000 years ago the end of
the last ice age sea level by tide
gauges the level has been rising since
20 years ago 20 thousand years 20
thousand the energy
yeah it's been a natural rise so first
of all sea level's always been rising
for 20 000 plus years second of all if
you look at tide gauges it's about the
thickness of a nickel rise per year and
if you look at satellite which they
started in 93 i think it's like triple
or maybe double that rate or maybe a one
and a half times that rate but there's
dueling data sets and even if you accept
their high end it would take
3 500 years to get the sea level rise
that al gore warned about in his film
and inconvenient truth 3 500 3 500 years
if you were to believe humans were
accelerating it but the point is sea
level rise is natural if you're worried
about sea level rise you can look at
what the dutch did there's all sorts of
things you can do with that and that
requires development economic growth and
also wise building plans you don't want
to put all these houses on the beach
because it's a natural thing happening
anyway so
but it's important to go back to the
neil tyson degrasse because that is
expert
judgment expert consensus that's the way
they've done this that goes back to the
whole 97 percent consensus
these are scientists people trust them
you know four out of five dentists
recommend this toothpaste 97 a scientist
says we had richard toll who i
interviewed he was a lead author of the
united nations report looked into the 97
consensus done by an australian named
john cook the underlying data he said
the consensus in that paper was quite
literally pulled from thin air
there's another paper uh of 97 percent
and they got a survey of 10 000
scientists whittled it down to 77 and
they came up with 75 answered the the
survey is the earth warming to humans
contribute they came out with a 97
consensus that way even though there
were questions a lot of skeptical
scientists would answer yes to
so this is important because when you
cut to the covet debate you put out a
credentialed expert who makes these
claims puts a little bit of data in but
and then tries to scare the public
because they're lobbing he's lobbying
you for a policy position there are you
basically saying that neil degrasse
tyson is the anthony fauci of climate
change i don't know enough about him i
don't think he's that bad no okay but i
do think he's lobbying for he's lobbying
it's not just he's not that bad he
doesn't have that kind of power right he
doesn't have that anthony anthony
thought she had actually power
and influence neil is is
also more careful i think generally than
falci falci was just all over the place
i don't know i i i
he doesn't come up who would be who
would be
the anthony fauci of you know climate
change who would that voice be well it
depends on again it's not nih it's not
going to be cdc who's that person going
to be who's leading the paris climate
accord well you have john kerry and uh
gina mccarthy are in the biden
administration so john kerry is the sort
of the climate the international climate
envoy and then you have gina mccarthy
who's like the domestic one and wasn't
carrie also the head of the iran nuclear
deal
yeah he was yes so he's doing climate
and nuclear and john kerry he's the
perfect spokesman for this but john
kerry you know he's he comes off he
doesn't do the cause any good for the
climate movement but
it comes and i have a whole chapter in
my new book on this whole idea of
credentialed scientists
in the the whole process and essentially
what they do is they're using science as
a lobbying tool and i think it was
thomas soul whose famous quote was you
know science government science or they
bring in the science when to support
decisions already made by bureaucrats
essentially or by government and that's
what they do it's very easy to find
any position you want when it comes to
science like that
and you line up in administration give
you a case in point biden has an epa
advisory board that was there they
didn't like any of the trump appointees
so i think they're getting rid of like
50 plus of these scientists
because they wouldn't agree with biden's
view on climate and environment so once
they get rid of them within a year when
piden proposes a new environmental
protection agency climate rule they can
credibly say there wasn't any decent and
i knew 100 of our scientists all agreed
with it well if you'd been paying
attention a year ago they just
eliminated a third of the scientists
because they knew they wouldn't agree
they just removed them from the board
this is how they create science
consensus you have these national
academy of science the american
meteorological the american geophysical
union
look at this they came out with a
statement in support of al gore in the
u.n tens of thousands of scientists
endorsed the view that climate is
causing harm oh really it was a
governing board of two dozen or so
elected officials voted without direct
vote or input of the of the members that
tens of thousands of members of these
groups in the case of american
meteorological society there were
studies that up to 75 at one point were
skeptical a man-made climate change at
least 50 but it didn't matter because
the two dozen governing board members
steeped in politics lobbying
and government connections voted that we
agree with the un al gore view and so
that whole organization there's another
one of the consensus can those thousands
of scientists be wrong
that was the whole point of the way it's
just about stopping debate stopping
stuff so that we have to accept the
premise and then we have to be accept
they're forced rushed solution because
we don't have time to act we're running
out of time
you've used the word consensus multiple
times in your in your last uh statement
right there so i just want to hone in on
consensus you see the stat 97 of
scientists believe this
right
um obviously you take different
positions in these people but like even
if you use the abortion
um
debate you know
pro-life pro-abortion protest pro-that
pro-choice
you know they find consensus that they
both agree in the life of the mother
okay the health of the mother right
whether you believe in pro-choice
pro-abortion whatever pro-life you
believe you want the health of the
mother
where do you find consensus with the
people you wholeheartedly disagree with
is there anything that we at least the
general public can understand
this this and this is actually real what
is it we've warmed since the end of the
little ice age in 1850 i think that's
not no one disputes that and since that
was a you know
so on either side just happening that
would be except copy check it's just now
disputed about the medieval war period
and the roman warrior period because
they went back and revised all of that
history uh we generally there's a broad
agreement that more co2 would equal a
warmer world theoretically meaning if
it's not canceled out by something else
but but then you get into disagreements
agreement that co2 bad no that it would
add to warming not necessarily bad
because there's a theories about
saturation point once you hit a certain
point of co2 more does not make it
warmer it sort of levels out uh there's
also
the whole geologic history we've had ice
age with many times higher co2 but
generally
there's a whole contingent of scientists
who say no there is no greenhouse effect
but they're small but otherwise
that's generally agreed upon the co2
adds warmth but there's also so many
factors hundreds of factors that
influence the climate tilts of the earth
clouds water vapor ocean cycles
volcanoes
and the sun obviously
so the idea that you can tease out one
and say this is the cause this is the
finger of or climate catastrophe co2 is
the finger control the climate not the
case and that's in terms of the
scientists that are dissenting that's
where you get the dispute but
essentially that co2 warms temperatures
gone up since 1850
beyond that arctic ice has dropped since
the 1970s again that was the height of
the uh global cooling scare but then
it's disputed because there may have
been similar levels of arctic ice in the
20s 30s and early 40s which including
greenland
uh
polar bears i think it's generally
agreed that the numbers have gone up and
you know why that but that's not a
public agreement but i'll tell you why
it's agreement polar bears are
disappearing but they're disappearing
from al gore's books and movies and
climate activist brochures why is that
because conservation and all these
different environmental groups all admit
that we've never had this many polar
bears it's the highest they've ever
counted they did a hunting ban back in
the 70s late 60s 70s but the numbers
have gone up dramatically roughed over
30 000. gore made it the poster child in
his first film never mentioned him in
his second film or his book at the same
time 2017. so that's generally agreed
upon but they won't talk about it you
know that kind of stuff so
in terms of beyond that uh if you listen
carefully john kerry agrees that the you
know the u.n paris agreement zeroing out
industrial emissions for the west would
have no impact on co2 emissions but
these are all said disjointed at
different times and reaction moments of
candor
um
but otherwise
i'm trying to think what else is general
agreement on
the the debate you did with bill nye was
seven years ago yeah it was not built i
was on well i did three meetings
one was under so one was on piers morgan
and one was and how often do you do do
you do debates like that great question
you used to do them all the time i mean
all the time i mean in the from 2000 to
2016
it was regular debating
donald trump won the media said we could
never allow someone like him to win
again we can no longer allow dissent and
they just stopped it all but i was doing
that regularly abc news uh cnn regularly
on seeing a don lemon show they would
have me oh we were oh but then they just
they decided that
scott pelley cbs news anchor then cbs
news anchor said i will not interview a
climate denier for the same reason i
won't interview a holocaust denier
when's the last time that you did a
debate
well with the guy at the heritage but
the only debates they allow now are with
other republicans who believe climate's
a problem want free market solutions now
that i'm trying to think that's a
problem because
they're silencing yes they have the
outlier debate was dan bongino
had wanted me to debate the un report
last summer in august of 2021 they
couldn't find anyone they ended up
getting some surrogate biden spokesman
who didn't really know anything about
the climate he just read a couple
talking points but beyond that it's been
years because they will and there's no
it's not just me but no one's allowed to
debate it's very very rare well listen i
i got some devastating news that just
came in and i hate to ruin your days um
anthony fauci said he will not continue
if trump becomes a president
i don't want you guys to be disappointed
by that
uh i know america is probably look we're
probably gonna lose a thousand people
right now getting off immediately
because this is to be very disturbing
for them but
you know
i don't know if you read what he said
yesterday he said if question was asked
if trump wins will you stay he says no
i'll resign and move on so fortunately
he's also 85 years old it's time for him
to be oh no no no
the video was specific about him not
continuing if it's not true i'm sure but
i just again i hate to do this too
because i know bothers you a lot but i
don't want to do that to you and another
number came out yesterday i don't know
if you saw the other number that came
out yesterday because you know how every
time they'll say biden's approval rating
is the worst we've had except for
donald trump yeah well officially can't
say that anymore because it's the worst
ever measured yeah dude again two things
back to back within a minute adam uh
approval rating has been the worst in
the last 100 years
uh to the point where you know things
are bad when msnbc
put stories up saying if this goes the
way the 75 percent is not happy about
the direction it's going uh with biden
yesterday there was a question asked of
the new press secretary having to do
with the shortages and inflation because
you know they're trying to blame
inflation on corporate taxes and then
jeff bezos i don't know if you saw the
jeff bezos store if you want to put that
up bezos has never i don't think i've
ever seen bazel say anything negative
about a
president on the left and yesterday he
just popped off on twitter
i'm like dude were you having a bad date
that you and your girl get into a big
fight
can you make that a little bit bigger
and click on the jeff bezos tweet not
the other one uh is that the right one
or no
i'll find it
just just type to click on his profile
it'll go to because he doesn't tweet
that often just go up a little bit
you'll see it
um
yeah zoom in you'll see it right there
just zoom in
zoom in go up a little bit go up a
little bit go up a little bit the one
right above it i think 200 amazon uh no
that's not it can you find what he says
to
uh oh i think is it the one that says
the best way i think that was it hey
there it is the newly created
disinformation board should review this
tweet by joe biden or maybe they need to
form a new
new non-uh
sequitur board instead raising corporate
taxes is fine to discuss taming
inflation is critical to discuss
mushing them together is just
misdirection by the way this is a man
who hates trump okay this is a man who
him and must go at it all the time you
know they're they're opposing sides and
this is a man who supported this guy and
he's saying this publicly on twitter
look how many likes it's his most liked
tweet of all time okay is that right joe
biden on
look at the click on joe now if you look
at bazel's tweets he doesn't get a lot
of likes look at the like before
thirteen thousand six thousand thirty
five hundred you know two thousand five
thousand and then boom
170 000 people agree with this guy click
on joe biden's tweet by the way click on
joe biden's tweet you want to bring down
inflation let's make sure the wealthiest
corporation pay their fair share
do you realize even if you taxed a
hundred percent of the wealthiest people
it still wouldn't do nothing
if you tax them a hundred percent it
wouldn't do anything
uh with uh where we're at so by the way
in regards to climate change did you
hear what uh pinterest just said
pinterest just said uh last week i think
pinterest will not take down content
spreading climate change misinformation
this is uh uh let me go to what story
what page is that on it's on page three
i'll read this to you and then i'll get
your commentary on everything we just
discussed right now
so uh uh pinterest will take down uh
content spreading the climate change
mister formation
uh uh the announcement shows pinterest
known for providing a space to share
ideas about clothing food and furniture
is also getting into uh sustainability
the company is launching a preemptive
striking against climate change
information becoming the first social
media network to prohibit
users from sharing inaccurate data about
climate change the site will now use a
combination of automation and human
review to find misinformation remove it
and replace it with accurate articles
about climate change yeah well my only
first comment is i can't believe they
weren't doing that already i just
thought i assumed they all were it's
just sad because
youtube just recently demonetized any
climate skeptics from even getting
anything not that it didn't affect me
but the same thing everyone cheering on
what they did for russia
right after the invasion into ukraine
where
banking government corporations all got
together and immediately just went after
and essentially shut the same thing that
trudeau did to the uh
truckers in canada
be very afraid because they can use that
directly back on someone if you hold
anti-covet views if you hold
anti-climate views anti-you know viral
scare views
this is all part essentially
you know davos crowd glass schwab small
narrow window to reset our world
disinformation control of it is probably
the one of the most important things a
lot of their training sessions for
covert they talked about shutting down
the internet to stop misinformation
so i'm sure pinterest probably has a
covet policy very similar and this is
just the first steps they're going to
keep going and any i almost said idiot
but any person out there who says so
private company they should be able to
do what they want nothing's private
anymore big tech censorship is
government censorship when the white
house gives issues lists of names for
big tech corporations to censor and then
they follow suit and do it this is no
longer private companies so that's where
i get i get really angry with a lot of
the people on the
libertarian conservative who just think
oh this is this is their this is their
choice they can do it i don't know the
way to fight it is i don't think elon
musk is buying twitter by the way
everything i'm seeing is i think he's
looking for an out he's saying it's full
of bots and he's the whole deal is on
hold i have a feeling he's gonna walk
from this i think he just probably
doesn't want the hassle and i think in
the long term interest just personally
him it would probably destroy tesla if
he did what he's talking about doing at
twitter there the establishment's pet
company they will destroy that company
no matter what he's done on climate no
matter how popular he's been they will
get him and and they have the power to
do that even to the world's wealthiest
man they will dismantle him i i don't
think it's a good move if he doesn't if
he backs out of it well he's looking for
a way i know he is i know what he's
doing because the whole 120 million
dollars that you know they're they're
trying to say because you waited a few
days you save yourself this much money
by doing that and the
now uh they're trying to investigate him
so obviously the one thing that's
obvious forget about the fact that
whether he wants to buy it or not
no one on the left wants him to buy
nobody yeah even yesterday did you see
what the twitter ceo of twitter tweeted
yesterday and how he almost reacted to
it so yesterday the ceo twitter put out
how to address the uh fight off all the
bots
[Music]
and he wrote out a series of tweets
uh and elon musk's
so he says let's talk about spam and
let's do with the benefit of data facts
and context okay and he explains it in
this 10-part tweet or 15-part tweet that
he puts
and then on the bottom
what does uh how does elon must respond
to it with a go go up go up go to
replies now go all the way up and go to
replies right there second one that says
replies and zoom in a little bit because
we can't see anything zoom in a little
bit okay keep going keep going keep
going and yeah there you go move it this
is how he responds there not that one
keep going you have to see how what he
responds with what emoji there it is
right there okay so process
unfortunately we don't believe that
senator jones platforms are gonna so the
the part about uh the bots elon musk
responds
with a what emoji is that emoji
emoji okay a poop emoji that's
essentially if he buys a company that's
a ceo but he responds with a poop emoji
i don't think it's a good move for musk
to back out i don't think it's a good
move for muslim background he must he i
just read
alex berenson did a thing he alex
berenson thinks the deal's over it's not
going to happen i don't know
he was probably looking at a collapse of
his whole enterprise possibly i mean
they would be ruthless in going after
him i mean he could lose they're going
to be released no matter what with them
well even now but less so now because if
he backs down i think i i i i it appears
to me he's he's looking for every out
but i don't know if he'll get an out
we'll see because now i think twitter's
suing him for the original deal it's
it's getting uh messy but
i i hope twitter
actually forces them to buy it okay i
hope they do okay because
the calls i'm getting the calls i'm
getting is i'm getting calls and i'm
getting on you know morgan stanley's
leading this whole thing goldman and
symbol but it's really morgan stanley's
deal and they're he's looking for guys
to come in this is what up the calls
i've been on rounds of 100 million cash
because he wants to you know you know
leverage some of the folks who get in as
well but you don't get to say anything
but i hope the deal goes through i think
it's going to be a very
um he may if he buys twitter he may be
the most influential man in the world
because he's going to use his voice
if he buys it if he doesn't buy it
uh and he's smart enough to know how to
get out of it if there's anybody smart
enough to get out of a deal it's
probably a guy named elon musk let me
ask you about you're saying he's
basically looking for an off-ramp to get
out of the deal that's what it seems
like yeah because he's talking about
these bots and this was now an issue it
looks like the point of contention is is
the are these bots and these fake
accounts i've seen it i've seen is that
really what he's worried about or is
that is there a bigger i think he's i
think he's just i think he's i think all
his investors all his partners everyone
is telling them this is the end of tesla
and very well i mean i don't put
anything past them i mean in terms of
what i say them i mean the establishment
it'll be the end of tesla why if it goes
through i just think that they're going
to do everything they can in terms of
government contracts regulations
support it could affect his space
ender's rises because a lot of his the
whole world has been okay so the will
between government and private that's
exactly why
taking money from the government is the
is not a freaking good move because they
eventually yeah strong army like like
he's talking about did you get that
spacex would you make money
they'll eventually say if you do this
here's what we're gonna do because we
fed you this that's exactly why the
nationalized system doesn't work exactly
that's exactly why that doesn't work
punishes
individuality any dissent you have to
toe the party line on everything same
thing we saw on every i mean everything
from climate covert
um i was selling health insurance
obamacare comes out and all these guys
in l.a were like oh my god i'm selling
obamacare and afford let me tell you i
just sold 100 policies i japan we're
making money so much money man you got
to get in i'm like yeah bro there's one
person i don't compete with and that's
the government i'm out i left i'm like
i'm not touching health insurance at all
they forced everybody to use three or
five different insurance companies every
year i saw my premium going up for what
i had to pay for as an employer i'm like
yeah i'm not competing with you guys
you're right you win obama you win i'm
out we'll go to a different industry
that you're not going to be involved
what's the correlation there or the
lesson there with elon musk and what
he's doing with tesla and potentially
with twitter the correlation is
ah man let's look i'm watching you
you're watching this amber hurt and uh
johnny depp what a sweetheart of a girl
she is right just
listen to it the more the more i watch
her like they showed a recording
yesterday
of how she's like you know the attorney
says do you know why johnny doesn't look
at your eyes do you don't by the way you
have to use a restroom no no fine so do
you know why johnny doesn't look at your
eyes
and he's like no
do you look at johnny's eyes in court i
do does he look at you no do you know
why i don't know you should know i don't
know then she plays the recording
and it's a recording of johnny and amber
and she's like please stop touching me
he's like come on please i just want it
one more time i want to hug you because
i i know i'm so ugly i was like stop
touching me it says you will never
see these eyes look at you ever again
never you hear it in the recording
johnny got to point that i will never
can you imagine a
loved one telling you i will never make
eye contact because you know love the
eye contact i will never look at you
ever again right you've seen all these
things being revealed about where it's
at and how power structure and
manipulation when somebody gets a hold
of you dude amber heard is a small
government controlling a guy that she
almost ruined his life because he came
out and said this guy beat me you know
what was a question that the lawyer
asked i love the question says hey does
johnny always wear these rings as long
as i know he always has these rings on
is it fair to say these are not small
rings no is it fair to say he wears very
big gory rings you know not gory rings
like just god he rings yeah yes has he
always for as long as i know he's always
warned this he says okay great this is
the picture you showed that he hit you
you what would happen if he hit you with
these rings
you're like what a freaking great point
if he's hit you as many times as you
claim he's hit you how come you don't
have any scars for them from from these
rings this guy this girl ruined the
guy's life for what she did and he comes
out it's so weird can you imagine a man
saying yeah i'm suing my wife for
domestic violence yeah yeah that's your
emancipator right yeah anyways the
government yeah is doing
to
musk
what potentially amber heard
did to johnny and i hope
musk responds like johnny did
i hope musk responds like johnny did
because somebody has to stop the
bullying and if that is really what is
going on behind closed doors if there is
a guy that can do that it's this crazy
guy it's him
and that doesn't mean they're not going
to stop coming after you that doesn't
mean they're not going to stop uh
playing games with them that doesn't
mean they're not going to stop trying to
get sec tax they're going to find some
[ __ ] on this guy that if they want to do
it but the alternative is what you're
officially owned by the government you
officially have to get a tattoo that
says i'm government-owned property yeah
again and in my book on the great reset
i go into the whole digital currency
what they're trying to do and they're
actually done it now in several
countries i think it was zimbabwe or
and uh and obviously canada where
they're you're going to be
government joe biden just did an
executive order about three months ago
about a central bank digital currency to
essentially compete with cryptocurrency
the idea here though is
you're going to be relying on this
government your credit card will be shut
down your banking will be shut down if
you don't get a covert vaccine if you
don't uh support or yeah or fall out of
favor with the party and there's
actually a partnership now between the
united nations and mastercard called a
dichotomy a credit card where it's going
to monitor your carbon footprint and the
car the world economic forum is very
excited about this the card cuts off
your spending when you hit your carbon
footprint max in other words if you get
too much gas or if you you know fly buy
airline tickets your card stops working
now it's voluntary at the moment it's
for people who want to monitor it but
how long before that you know six months
a year before that becomes mandatory
that's all part of it control your
banking control your thermostat this is
about human freedom and that's
ultimately what the climate battle's
about and now the real battle and the
next transition of this is going to be
the viral battle and this pandemic
treaty i think is the greatest threat i
don't think they're going to win though
i don't think they're going to win it's
a question of how many years of darkness
before they lose that's the question
soviet union didn't win but they had 70
years think about it think about think
about building one of the most
ridiculous technologies of all time and
not wanting any credit for it
what are we talking about bitcoin
bitcoin oh okay and i'm not i'm not even
a bitcoin guy i have some bitcoin and
ethereum but i'm not the guy that's
going out there saying you know that's
but think about producing the greatest
one of the greatest technologies out
there and not caring for people to say
who you are like think about that even
about satoshi yeah whoever the satoshi
nakamoto is right like you know how some
people write these books that's not
their name what do they call it there's
a word for it
uh what is it called pseudonym right and
eventually what comes out yeah i wrote
that book you know is it really me that
wrote that book right
this guy still has not come out so how
do you process that here's how i process
that
for you to produce something like that
where you create a revolution in the
world essentially because everybody
governments are buying everybody's
talking about this bitcoin thing and
you're sitting there imagine imagine him
on the you know
you know sitting in his living room and
he's watching and saying
yeah
okay
you know what i should come out and tell
the world i build it i bet i'm going to
get more girls i bet i'm going to get
more of this i bet i'm gonna get more
respect i'm gonna i should go out there
and say no i really don't give a [ __ ]
that guy who produced it
is driven more by being left alone than
recognition yeah you you can they're not
gonna win you don't win with there's
people behind closed doors who are just
sitting around who are so powerful and
they don't even to impose their power on
you they don't care for the recognition
they don't give a [ __ ] for you to tell
them how special they are those are the
people that they're waking up so for me
i think common sense prevails and i
think they're waking up the wrong people
and those wrong people are ones who know
how to stand up to them i hope
i hope whoever is in elon's ear and is
talking to him
he also man who's going to make up his
own mind he's going to do what he's
going to do um
i hope he realizes buying one of these
virtual governments is very very
important to not let all of those guys
be on the same page it's very important
for somebody who is reasonable in the
middle to own one of the big social
media companies it would be
revolutionary it would put a
massive debt in all their places so so
to the point to the point where even if
the people who have money like this is
the part that you got to give credit to
the left and not the right the you know
what the left would do right say ilamas
was on the left selamus was on the left
and they had to figure out a way to come
together and get that money to make sure
this deal gets done or whatever it is
you know what they would do
they'd be doing zooms and calls and
conference calls to make sure everybody
came together and they'd be raising
money for each other to make sure they
got that money to make sure they own
twitter i hope the people on the other
side are also making calls and doing
whatever they can to help this man end
up owning twitter but at the same time
you know what you're saying with tesla
the fears i don't know man i hope he
stands up and he picks picks up twitter
because somebody opposing from the mob
needs to own one of the social media
companies someone needs to do it he's
pretty much the only one at this point
because they're so big and powerful it's
uh but by the way let me let me tell you
what kind of very weird thing happened
last 24 48 hours
kind of like the fact that bezos kind of
threw himself out there maybe bezos is
sitting there saying [ __ ] i'm not as
loved as musk is yeah because i'm
playing it so damn safe you know what
i'm the new rebel and i'm the new guy
you know what screw this [ __ ] of trying
to beat and mr nice guy worth 300
billion dollars and you know what forget
about it i'm in the game of recreating
myself i'm about to show you guys what
i'm really all about i'm gonna push my
weight as well i hope that
backbone comes out but you're just
hoping when that backbone comes up
people are not bought on the back end or
afraid of all these other fears that
people are going to bring who knows
what's going to end up happening uh
anyways today's been a blast having you
on thank you talk a lot of different
things folks if you enjoyed today's
podcast
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel and the book that's uh can they
get your book on amazon is your book
available on amazon book is green fraud
it's available on amazon and my new book
is the great reset and the permanent
lockdowns coming out august 28th i
believe so this one they can order i
know this one because the audible is out
yes this will lay out the entire
climate agenda including the history
behind it the going back the 1970s it
goes through the kids indoctrination
goes through covet climate connection it
goes to how the u.n was corrupted with
these extreme scenarios to scare
everyone
forward by mark stein and then the other
book is the great reset which goes the
world economic forum
prince charles uh all the big
corporations all aligning essentially
for a very narrow window to reset our
planet you'll own nothing you'll be
happy you'll have everything delivered
by drone you'll have no privacy uh
you'll be eating insects and printed
meat from a 3d printer
it's all their words and i try to do as
much mainstream sourcing but again this
is where i talk about the new politics
it's not left right anymore last
question for you um assuming the earth's
still here you know in the next 50 years
what do you want your legacy to be what
do you want to be known for
i want to be known as the man who
questioned authority and in the new book
i go back in the 1960s it was the left
who showed the way to go after the
pentagon to find the pentagon papers to
challenge the administration's claims on
vietnam war who knew that government
agencies lied to the public i want to
return i want to be the man now
championing that return question
authority question the consensus
question what you're told whether it's
climate covered vaccines uh or you know
all the all these so-called solutions
that's what i would like to be is this
let's have an open society once again
well i look forward to you actually
being in a heated fierce debate with
somebody that you guys can go back and
forth for a year and a half we've been
trying to invite people to debate we've
had plenty of people to debate on this
side from the other side no one wants to
do it for a year and a half we've been
trying this no one said no if you know
anybody that's an influencer and is on
the opposing side and is willing to
debate i'm sure you wouldn't mind having
them we'll host a debate right here if
you know anybody that you'd like to see
this debate youtube keep it on though is
the question if it's a debate they'll
keep it on because they kept alan
dershowitz and uh i like that uh robert
kennedy well i would like to see a round
two debate
with mark
brother thanks for coming out this was
great thank you thank you everybody bye
bye bye bye by the way no podcast
thursday we'll be back next week i'm out
of the country take care guys bye-bye
you